let's go to the 6-1-6 area code a caller
from the 6-1-6 let us know your name
where you're calling from and jump right
into your question if you want hey this
is Derrick calling from Grand Rapids
Michigan otherwise known as a divorce
country excellent
what's going on so with the recent
cultural awareness of sexual harassment
companies I seem to be getting better
about responding to sexual harassment
when it happens but do you think
companies should be doing cars should be
taking more steps to actively prevent or
discourage it from happening in the
first place
I mean you know the thing about
preventing sexual harassment is that if
you get to the point of being employed
as an adult without already
understanding the limits of
appropriateness is a company policy
really going to change your behavior and
I think it's important for companies to
have procedures in place for dealing
with it when it happens and saying okay
when there are allegations we will
suspend the person pending an
investigation but they will be paid and
only if we determine the allegations are
true will they be fired for example or
we let people work through
investigations you the company needs to
set a policy right but you know when I
worked at Circuit City when I was in
college I was shown some video we were
shown a bunch of indoctrination videos
before we started working one of them
was about how bad unions are that we
wouldn't try to unionize and another one
had something in it about you know not
sexually harassing people basically if I
had started at Circuit City as a 17 year
old or however old I was with no
understanding of the fact that it's
wrong to sexually harass people is
seeing the video going to prevent me
from from doing it so I think that the
the problem is well beyond the company's
you know what I mean Derrick yeah for
sure yeah all right well he's already
follow up on that but you have maybe
there should be more recourse for
lower-level employees I think the
reasons why gretchen carlson waited so
long to come out and make allegations
against roger ailes was that she
would've been subject to firing if she
did so yeah so I think that that's a
good point Derrick that Pat is making
which is the part that can be difficult
is the power dynamics and why people in
positions of less power
particularly when
they're being harassed by a supervisor
there really needs to be a clear way
that they can feel comfortable coming
forward without risking job
repercussions yeah and especially a lot
of the problems you know stems from the
fact that men overwhelmingly are in
positions of power in these companies or
you know in the culture at large yeah
and you know if you have a sexual
harasser at the very top of the chain
that can't really lead to much work
going down the chain yeah you go if you
go to the person who was hired by the
guy at the top and say the guy at the
top is bothering me are they are is that
person even in a position of power to do
something about it a very very good
point thanks Derek for the question I
appreciate it thanks take care all right